el enfoque Internacional del presidente
del gobierno de España se afianza tras
viajar a Ucrania en febrero a China en
marzo y recibir a líderes de
latinoamérica como el brasileño Lula da
Silva o el presidente de Colombia
Gustavo Petro hace unas semanas Pedro
Sánchez Está ya en Estados Unidos para
reunirse con su homólogo en la Casa
Blanca Estados Unidos y España citan
excelentes relaciones entre ambas
naciones y según fuentes de la monclo a
la reunión se basará en tres ejes por un
lado los objetivos de la presidencia
española de la Unión Europea en el
segundo semestre del año con temas como
la llamada autonomía estratégica por la
que Europa quiere reindustrializarse y
desligarse de la producción asiática
Pero esto choca con el plan de reducción
de la inflación de biden que podría
tener un efecto llamada de inversores
hacia el otro lado del Atlántico que
desfavorecería al viejo continente por
otro lado su relación bilateral con
varios acuerdos en temas de seguridad y
defensa cooperación científica y
tecnológica o de lucha contra la
emergencia climática sin embargo los
desafíos internacionales dominarán las
discusiones la guerra en Ucrania con
detalles de lo que Sánchez y sí hablaron
en Beijing y las posibles salidas al
conflicto pero sin duda la migración un
fenómeno que afecta a ambos países de
primera mano centrará el encuentro la
cooperación es Clara Sánchez Se
compromete a crear nuevos programas de
migración circular con latinoamérica que
supla las carencias de personal de
trabajo en España y así rebajar la
presión en las fronteras estadounidenses
justo cuando finaliza el título 42 con
inmigrantes agolpándose con la esperanza
de poder cruzar al norte